hey guys it is currently way way late in
the game drums office and you can tell
because my voice is starting to get a
little bassy but either way I just
wanted to make a vlog because I haven't
since the start of the new year and I
wanted to say how well this new year has
been going um I've been really keeping
my schedule I don't know if you guys
have been able to tell but everyday
except for one occasion now is YouTube's
fault not mine I've been uploading at 8
a.m. Pacific time and noon pacific time
which translates to 11:00 a.m. and 3:00
p.m. Eastern Standard Time and some
other time in the UK whatever that time
may be but it has been working out well
for me because it is forced me to keep a
schedule and a schedule is incredibly
important because it forces me to plan
ahead which means that it forces me to
make videos ahead of time and it forces
me to adhere to something that gives you
guys like content on a regular basis and
also by doing that it's been taking some
time to get adjusted to it I've had just
a few nights where I've stayed up way
late making videos not but tonight is
one of those nights but it it allows me
more free time and that's really
important to me because I haven't been
able to have free time in a long time
like I've been obsessing about my
channel and I do that because I love you
guys and I really want you guys to be
happy with the videos that I make and I
want to make sure that you guys are
always happy with it but if I can have
the best of both worlds it's even better
and it has been and also it means that
I'm gonna be preparing for events like
pax South which is coming up in San
Antonio Texas I'm leaving this Thursday
for San Antonio
oh also Bob and Wade are both gonna be
there and we are having a panel all
together there on Friday at 1 p.m. in
the Bobcat theater also at 1 p.m.
there's a roosterteeth panel scheduled
so I don't know which one you'll want to
go I wish I hope that you'll want to go
to ours but I understand that there's a
lot of fan crossover and they've got
some cool stuff scheduled really Bob
Wade and I we're just going to be
hanging out
room and interacting with you guys and
answer your questions and running into
the audience rampantly tried to answer
your questions if you didn't see the
first panel that me and Wade ever did
you can I'll try to find the video and
put a link in the description below so
that you can watch it it was so much fun
to do and it was so interesting to be
among you guys and like be on that stage
and just being able to be silly and have
fun so I can't wait for Bob to be there
too because this is Bob's first
convention Wade has been going around to
a few but bob has never gone to a gaming
specific convention I believe he may
have gone to other ones at some point
he's like but that doesn't matter cuz he
done YouTube now and that's all that
matters now but just you know for
everyone that's going to pack South in
San Antonio please feel free to say hi
to us we will be walking around together
most of the time and then separating I
guess whenever we feel like it but
please please please feel free to come
up say hi to us at any time
don't feel like you have to wait or
anything like that unless there's a huge
line don't just cut in front of everyone
but just say hi to us we're here to see
you guys we're here to hang out with you
guys we're here to have fun with you
guys so we want to do that so Friday at
the Bobcat theater at 1:00 p.m. and then
there's gonna be a signing at some point
in the future after that you can check
the schedule on the pack south side
there's more information there but just
thank you guys so much for continuing to
support the channel because I don't know
if you've been paying attention but
we're already it like over five and a
half million subscribers and we just hit
5 million we're out getting up to 6:00
and like there's no slowing down and
there's no time to catch my breath so
that's why it's so important also that I
I keep up with it so that you guys are
at a loss for what's going on the
channel so just thank you guys so much
for being there for me I can't wait to
see you guys back south I can't wait to
meet you guys more as time goes on once
I have more time hopefully I'll be able
to go to more conventions maybe even in
the UK maybe even in Australia maybe
even in other countries around the world
because I meant to do that in 2014
didn't get a chance but this year is
gonna be different this year is gonna be
better
so either way thank you all so much for
watching check out those videos I
mentioned in the description below
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye